at the incident command center in chico
california
crews from all over california are
working in the dixie fire zone
and not only are they facing flames
they're also battling what seems
like dense fog but it's only smoke and
when the smoke clears the sun warms the
ground
and things change today we're going to
see those
air masses start moving very quickly
what does that mean for the firefighters
on the ground
erratic windy fire behavior and that can
create
lightning which could spark more fires
the monsoonal moisture coming into the
area
along with the heat created by the sun
the heat created by the fire
we're putting ourselves into a package
that potentially could cause some very
erratic very
aggressive fire behavior today well at
least
21 structures have been lost since the
fire was sparked on july 13th
but in this community of indian falls
nearly every home has been destroyed
remarkably though an american flag is
still flying high
seemingly untouched by the fire but
despite all this destruction and the
amount of acres burned
firefighters are praising their crews to
be able to report that we've got 190
000 acres burned and nobody injured
nobody dead
that's really good news it means those 5
000 crew
members that are out there fighting the
fire
are doing things properly